so laughter you learned some new chords
the first thing you want to do is play a
full song with them right so here's a
nice simple song it only uses four
chords in fact for 90% of the song it
only uses three chords and it's quite
easy to play once you master the
transitions between them so this is Ed
Sheeran's Lego house in the key of G
I'm gonna pick up the pieces and build a
Lego house things go wrong we can knock
it down
my three words have two meanings it's
one thing on my mind it's all for you
it's not you go December I got you
okay now major and keep you sheltered
from the storm that's raging on now I'm
not a touch I'm out of love I'll pick
you up when you're down
and out of all these things I've done I
think I love you better now I'm out of
sight I'm out of mind I'll do it all for
you in time and out of all these things
I love
I'm gonna paint you by numbers color you
give things go right we can play this
and put you on a wall it's so hard to
say it but I beat it before now
surrender up my heart swap it for yours
some out of touch I'm out of love I'll
pick you up when you're getting down
never all these things I think I love
you better now
I'm out of sight am i but to you know
for you
love all these things up if you love you
better now don't hold me down
but grace is a break here and it's more
than that contain it's not gonna kill
December but I got you to keep whoa
there's broken now minja
it'll keep you sheltered from the storm
that's raging oh now I'm out of touch
I'll pick you up when you're down all
these things I love you
I'm outside I'm out of mind I'll do it
all for you in time all these things
happen
attached
when your get down
all these things I love you better
I'm out of sight I'm out of mind
do we know for you in time and out of
all these things have done I will love
you that